all right halloween last night folks
though they are experiencing some real
nightmares today travelers woke up
canceled flights from one of the
nation's largest carriers the alcohol
and joining us live from the karen
airport bianca i can imagine people are
frustrated just feels like here we go
again
the american airline passengers we spoke
with are tired and fed up some finding
out their flight was canceled less than
12 hours before their intended departure
and if also this morning we found out
there were about 200 cancellations
across the country
i got an email an hour ago saying my
flight was delayed until wednesday
everything just got messed up when they
canceled our flight clive toms and bobby
williams are two of the thousands of
american airline passengers unable to
get home on time
visiting from chicago williams says even
with the food and room vouchers there
are a lot of extra costs we have to miss
our jobs for two days i have five kids
at home you know what i'm saying i have
to pay extra babysitter we got cars at
the airport that we have to pay for you
know what i'm saying transportation back
to you know what i'm saying we just we
lost american airlines reports weather
issues at the carrier's main hub in
texas coupled with staffing issues
caused the cancellations but some people
are thinking twice about flying with
american again no not no not right now
sure was it i'm not doing anything else
for a minute i'm not going
y'all
it's just a lot
now american airlines did release a
statement stating that on november first
about a thousand
flight attendants will be returning to
work from leed and then also during the
holiday season they would have 600 new
hires starting the alcoholman live local
now